-Working here at the show is
a lot like camp
I would say, right?
There's a lot of activities
throughout the day.
We eat a lot of meals together.
We work long hours,
so people spend a lot of times
away from their families.
And we have a lot of fun here,
but it's important
to stay connected.
It's a camp tradition
that everyone
has to write home once a day.
So here at the show,
we're making letters home
something of a rule.
And just like my camp counselors
had to do with me,
I'm checking in with everybody
else to make sure
that they are all writing
their letters.
So, let's see, Quest -- Quest,
do you have your letter ready?
-Yeah, here, Jimmy, here.
-Oh, cool.
-Hey, Mom.
It's me, Questlove.
[ Laughter ]
The summer's really been great
so far.
Being the band leader at "The
Tonight Show" is the best job
in the world because I get to
spend all day
playing music with my friends.
The only thing is my bunkmate,
Tariq,
keeps eating all the brownies
you send.
So please send more
and this time with a lock
that only I know
the combination to.
Or a box labelled
"maybe poison."
[ Laughter ]
Also, he snores and he raps
in his sleep too.
He sleep-raps.
And they're not even that good.
I recorded him last night.
Listen to this.
-[ Slowly ] ♪ My name's Tariq
and I'm here to say ♪
♪ I like to rhyme
in a major way ♪
♪ I can rap like this,
I can rap like that ♪
♪ I can rap me out
because I'm the rapping dog ♪
♪ Hee haw ♪
[ Snoring ]
-Anyway, I miss you guys.
Oh, P.S., I won an Oscar.
Love, Quest.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a great letter home.
That's a great letter home.
Thank you very much, Quest.
Let's check in with
one of our editors.
Mark, do you have your letter?
-Sure do.
Dear Mom and Dad, I've been
having lots of fun as an editor
at "The Tonight Show."
But the job can be
pretty stressful.
I've gone from smoking a pack
a day to smoking a pack an hour.
Sometimes I just put an elastic
band around all the cigarettes
like this and smoke them
all at once.
It's a lot more efficient.
I guess you could say
I'm some kind of genius.
By the way, I'll try to come
home next week for my birthday.
Can't believe I'm turning 24.
[ Laughter ]
Sincerely, Mark.
[ Applause ]
-That's so nice.
Oh, that's sweet.
I knew him when he was 21.
-Yeah.
-Let's check in with one of
our producers, Brian McDonald.
Brian, will you please
read your letter?
-Hey, family, it's your favorite
son, Brian.
I'm having a great time
at the show.
But I'm actually writing to tell
you I'm permanently
changing my name to Ryan.
When I started here
over a decade ago, one guy
called me Ryan in a meeting
and I didn't say anything.
And now it's 10 years later and
everyone still calls me Ryan.
It's been so long,
I'm starting to question
if my real name ever was Brian.
[ Laughter ]
Or maybe it was Ivan.
I think I'll just go with Rylan.
Yeah, Rylan.
See you soon.
Love, Brian.
Damn it.
-Alright. Excellent.
[ Applause ]
Excellent job.
Excellent. These are great.
Now let's hear from one of
our writers, Martin.
Martin, will you please read
your letter?
-Dear Mom and Dad,
this is the weirdest space camp
I've ever been too.
Nobody ever wears their
astronaut suits except for me.
And any time I ask about
taking the shuttle,
they send me in a Chevy Suburban
to LaGuardia Airport.
[ Laughter ]
I haven't learned a single thing
about the Space Force program
yet, but "The Tonight Show"
announcer, Mr. Steve Higgins,
said that if I was interested,
he could sell me something
that would make me
"feel weightless AF."
[ Laughter ]
Sounds fun.
So please send sixty dol--
[ Laughter ]
Please send $70 cash.
I love you.
Please send me money.
-Thank you, Martin.
Jeff Goldblum is on the show
tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jeff, do you have a letter
for us?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dearest mater and dear pater,
things are going well for me
in entertainment.
I'm having so much fun being
a guest on
"The Jimmy Fallon Show."
Earlier, Jimmy came to
my dressing room
and said "hi" to me.
And then after that,
I said "hi" to him.
[ Laughter ]
The dressing room had a lot of
nice snacks, like carrots,
celery, those little containers
of hummus
with the pretzels in the lid.
There were some Triscuits
and cashews,
almonds, even Jordan almonds.
You know them?
They're candy-coated
like a fancy M&M,
but no chocolate,
not even a little.
Despite that, they're still a
tasty treat, a treat best suited
for someone with hard teeth like
a Lorne Greene
or a James Garner.
Also, "Jurassic World: Dominion"
is coming out soon,
and I play a character in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm glad that everyone's
doing it.
I can't wait to see this.
Thank you, Jeff.
Of course, I always write home,
too.
And as usual, I'd like to write
a note, please.
I'll use my letter-reading
voice.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dip that ink.
[ Medieval music plays ]
-[ British accent ]
To my dearest mumsy and dadsy,
my deepest and sincerest
apologies.
'Tis been many a fortnight since
I corresponded with thee last,
but I've been terribly busy now
that the new season of
"Stranger Things" hath dropped.
Netflix and chilling
I've been indeed.
[ Laughter ]
As thou might surmise from
the show's curious moniker,
'tis a veritable phantasmagoria
of odd occurrences
befalling a ragtag band of chums
in the year of our Lord 1986.
Oh, how I meant to phone thee
upon finishing, but I was
woefully indisposed after
imbibing an entire container of
something called
Mountain Dew Flamin' Hot.
My word, the only stranger
things I've encountered
since that are --
Sorry.
Can I erase?
[ Laughter ]
Now, here we go.
-Re-dip.
-My word, the only stranger
thing I've encountered since
are what this vile beverage doth
wrought upon my innards.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, I hope this latest
missive finds you well.
I low-key miss you both ever
so much, no cap.
Your most humblest of sons,
James Tiberious Fallon.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
Those are our "letters home."
We'll be right back with
Jeff Goldblum, everyone.